are you looking for some books to read
to up your machine learning game
or to just learn machine learning in the
first place keep watching because i'm
about to tell you
five of my personal favorites i'm
richard and this is richard on data
so all the books that i'm going to go
through here are really going to help
you become knowledgeable in machine
learning
but just keep in mind with machine
learning just like any other aspect of
data science
it really does require some real
practical experience
before you become a true expert at it
but these books will provide you some
much needed intuition
they're going to give you tools to
attack problems and oftentimes they're
going to give you some chunks of code
which might even help you implement
things pretty quickly now i'm mostly
targeting people here who are beginner
to intermediate level at machine
learning
because i think that's the general level
that most people subscribe to my channel
are at
now that's not to say that getting a
refresher from these books
won't be helpful to you if you consider
yourself more advanced
maybe you've been doing ml for seven to
eight or more years
no i think these books will benefit you
too but i think lots of people who are
in their early stages of machine
learning
just want a couple books that they can
really sink their teeth into
and most of these books are pretty
comprehensive so you don't have to go
and read every single one of them
but having said that generally the more
you read the more you're gonna learn
now before i unveil these five awesome
books i have to do my usual spiel where
i ask you to
number one subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already
also take half a second and smash the
like button
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
also in the description of this video i
will have a link to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me over there it would mean the
world to me
also as one important disclaimer i am
going to have amazon
links in the description to every single
one of these books
and if you click on that link and
purchase one of these books
i do receive a small commission from
that having said that though
several of these books are freely
available online
or at the very least they have code
chunks that are available on github
so wherever possible i will provide
those links as well so you can get as
much as you can
out of these books without having to pay
a dime now without further ado
let's get into these five books and then
at the end i'm gonna have one honorable
mention
the first book is the hundred page
machine learning book by andrey burkhoff
and at the time i'm recording this video
anyway it's distributed on the read
first by later principle so naturally
the link to that will be in the
description
so the name of this particular book is a
little bit misleading because it's
actually somewhere around 160 pages
but that doesn't change the fact that it
is a super quick read
easily the shortest one on this list and
naturally with a much shorter book
it doesn't really have the room to be
the most thorough or comprehensive one
on the planet
but i do think that for beginners and
newcomers there's tons of value
this book is structured to provide an
overview of the most important topics in
the machine learning ecosystem
and i really do think for a lot of
people there's value in knowing
what you need to know because data
science is so big and it
oftentimes really suffers from a lack of
structure
knowing what you need to know is
valuable in and of itself
and the writing on this book is
outstanding like if i had to describe it
in one word
it's punchy it's very easy to read it'll
cover a concept and spend enough time on
it but not too much
and then it'll segue very seamlessly
into the next concept
which is generally directly related or
similar
and at a bare minimum this one is great
to keep around as a reference
maybe you're doing some work you need a
quick shot reminder of what bagging and
boosting are exactly
well it's really easy to pick up this
book and get really solid definitions of
those things
in a couple minutes flat and this isn't
a coding book per se
but there are python snippets all
throughout it that code is all on github
the second book on this list should come
as no surprise to anyone who has even a
little experience with ml
because it's nothing short of classic
and that's an introduction to
statistical learning with applications
in r
by gareth james and others so this one
is actually of personal significance to
me
because it was actually one of two
textbooks that was used
in one of my major graduate level
courses on machine learning and
multivariate analysis and all that good
stuff
and this book is actually related to
another book which is elements of
statistical learning
now broadly speaking these books do
cover the exact same topics
but elements of statistical learning is
a little bit more in depth
and it's more geared towards people with
stronger mathematical backgrounds
an introduction to statistical learning
is a bit more geared towards people
without much mathematical background
it's shorter and the focus of it is on
application
this one is over 400 pages though so as
an introductory text
it's certainly a lot longer than the
last one but it does cover a very
comprehensive set of topics
you get your feet wet with linear
regression then it moves on to logistic
regression and discriminant analysis
then you start getting into things like
resampling methods
model selection and regularization
eventually it gets into tree based
methods and support vector machines
and then it closes everything off with a
chapter on unsupervised learning
most notably with principal component
analysis and k-means clustering
no neural networks in this book though
you've got to go to the elements of
statistical learning for that one
and this book is chock-full of extremely
useful r code
that's also on github too but overall
this book
it's well written it's thorough and it's
a must read for people getting into
machine learning
third book for this list is another book
based in r
and that's applied predictive modeling
by max khan
so for this one i have to give a little
bit of background
so mance kuhn is actually a software
engineer at r studio
and he's the creator of the package
carrot as well as the tidy model set of
packages
now the difference between these two is
completely the subject for a different
video
and my guess is that in the long run
things will start to go the way of tidy
models
but at the time i'm recording this video
which is october 2020
carrot is on version 6.0 and tidy models
is on version
0.1 it's important to point all this out
because this book does rely quite
heavily on the carrot package
what i love so much about this
particular book
from the standpoint of practicality and
applications
it's going to take you a lot further
than something straightforward like
spinning up a random forest model and
then measuring the performance
he dedicates a full chapter to talking
about how you measure predictor
importance there's another chapter on
all the different strategies out there
for dealing with class imbalance
and there's even a chapter on all the
practical problems with your data that
could cause model performance to suffer
then he has a chapter on feature
selection which he later would expand
upon
and turn into its own standalone book
it's not only that but he does a
terrific job
explaining on an algorithm-by-algorithm
basis
the types of data structures that are
going to cause that algorithm to fare
well
or poorly overall amazing book and even
if you're more of a python guy than an r
guy and maybe you're not planning to go
through all the code as he steps through
it
you're going to learn something if you
go through this book
fourth book is yet another classic and
that's hands-on machine learning with
scikit-learn
keras and tensorflow by aurelion garonne
some of you may be familiar with an
older version of this book but that was
before it was
updated with karis plus since then
there's been a whole new chapter added
on unsupervised learning
and a few chapters completely rewritten
now take a topic like support vector
machines
well this is another book that is going
to have a very heavy emphasis on
practicality
rather than the theoretical side of
things and i love it because as early as
chapter 2
this book gets you set up with jupiter
notebooks and scikit-learn
and guides you through a full beginning
to end machine learning project
and i'm not talking something super
basic where it's like two lines of code
i'm talking data transformation one-hot
encoding
feature scaling tons of really good
stuff and all that within the second
chapter of the book
now i do have to say this one is a
little bit more advanced as a python
book
than applied predictive modeling is as
an r book
and that should really come as no
surprise considering the second part of
this book
is all about tensorflow and keras all
that to say
we are getting to an intermediate level
here where you need to have
some working knowledge of python or you
are definitely going to hit some
stumbling blocks with this book
so the first half of this book is all
focused on the scikit-learn
stuff whereas the second part of the
book is where you get into the deep
learning stuff with applications in
tensorflow and keras
and i have to say if you're like most
people
you want to have a high level conceptual
understanding of deep learning
where you could explain it to a
stakeholder in the simplest possible
terms
and if that's the case this book is for
you you're not going to get into some
deep
theoretical understanding of
convolutional neural network
architecture
or these other concepts but you are
going to get the high level
and you're going to learn how to write
the code using the keras package
so you're able to implement these things
and this one will take most people a
little while to go through and read
and work through most of the code but i
promise you
it's going to be worth it then the last
book for this list
is approaching almost any machine
learning problem
by abhishek takur this is another python
book
it stands at just under 300 pages
and it's one that i've had the very
recent pleasure of reading myself
for that i have to give a shout out to
my friend and fellow content creator
ken g now this one as you might expect
from the title
is hyper focused on application and how
to approach
problems now as far as complexity and
the skill level required is concerned
i'd say it's roughly tied with hands-on
machine learning
that's to say i would not go into this
as my first
ever book on python nah i would go into
it with a little bit more experience
than that
but here's the beauty of this book of
all the books that i've talked about so
far in this video
this one is by far and away the one that
the highest percentage of it
is pure python code and it is structured
a little bit differently from the others
with most of the others typically
they're divided into chapters
where each chapter covers a new method
or technique
but this one is almost structured around
issues and problems
now don't get me wrong there is some
overlap like for instance there's one
chapter that's all about nlp
and text classification and regression
but you go from one chapter on
categorical variables and encoding
to another chapter on feature
engineering to another chapter on
feature selection
and just without fail the emphasis of
this book
is on approaching problems from
beginning to end
it's written in a very engaging way it's
designed to prep you for the curtails of
real world data
and it's for that reason this book is
possibly my favorite in this whole set
of books
all right now as promised we've gone
through the top five and i have
one honorable mention to bring up and
those of you with more experience with
machine learning
may be a little bit surprised that this
one didn't make the list
and that's deep learning by ian
goodfellow
this is a really well-known one and it's
good enough for elon musk
so this book is actually divided into
three distinct parts
and the first part is your standard
overview of your linear algebra
statistics calculus gradient descent you
know the basics
the second part is the real meat and
potatoes
and it's all about coverage of modern
deep learning techniques
now to be fair it does touch on other
topics
but the emphasis is on the methodology
behind deep learning techniques
then the third part is an even more
advanced coverage of the research
surrounding deep learning
with a particular focus on what the
future holds for deep learning as well
as
semi-supervised and unsupervised
learning
now i do have to be honest with this
book it is incredibly thorough
like it does cover deep learning from
beginning to end
but it's extremely dense and even if
you're somebody with a strong
mathematical background
this one can be seriously challenging to
read
you'll probably get a lot out of this
book if you're more advanced in the
subject
but honestly as a person who's neither
the best
nor the worst in the world at math but
does have a master's degree in stats
a lot of this one really does go over my
head
so that's just a buyer beware you can
really get a lot out of this book
but you need to be ready for it so
that's my top
five ml books for you and now i get it
most people aren't going to be able to
read every single one of these
because a lot of people they're busy and
they really only have time to dedicate
to a book
every three months or so on the side as
far as advancing their data science
skills are concerned
i really do think with any of these five
books
you're going to have a lot of new tools
at your disposal for attacking machine
learning problems as they come your way
and they're ultimately going to pay
enormous dividends for you
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please smash the like button
and then also let me know in the
comments down below what your favorite
machine learning book is
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data